présentée combattez pour partie mais
aussi un sportif oui
ok alors si ces bateaux de s
la leçon est un huitième édition dans le
cadre de la culture de jeu total dont ce
fait soit toute alliance avec les ter
n'est pas trop tôt et nous les lave ou
même la réunion en l'air pour m le hip
hop sont indiens ont l'air surtout le
break dance
m
ben
ils ont entre 10 et 14 ans 15 ans ce
qu'ils ont voulu représenter aujourd'hui
c'est juste qu'ils ont voulu faire un
spectacle bien sûr il ya toujours ce
cette connotation battles mais on
privilégie beaucoup de spectacle parce
que ya un public et un jury et en veut
tout le monde s'amuse donc un peu dans
les couleurs ils sont sa feu d'artifice
qu'on a voulu représenter aujourd'hui
l'exigence est bien manger bien dormir
et me concentrer à l'entraînement et
surtout avoir confiance en soi
environ 80 danseurs qui sont aujourd'hui
la finale ça sert surtout à apprendre de
l'expérience à affronter les coûts les
voisins de l'océan indien de prendre
niveau de s'entraîner chaque année pour
une finale un bateau de renommée et
voilà à l'époque en 2005 on pensait pas
que ça allait arriver à là et voilà on y
est à ce niveau là avec six pays dont la
boucle seychelles maurice madagascar
afrique du sud réunion et maurice
comment
pâques c'est surtout les jeunes tous ces
jeunes là qui nous voient voilà c'est
surtout la démocratisation du hip hop
pourtant une culture un peu mieux
compris un peu mieux considérer voilà
que c'est pas que des délinquants mais
justement ça nous permet de transférer
transformer tout le négatif en positif
c'est la force des mêmes valeurs du
sport voilà c'est une culture c'est un
as tu une philosophie est fou pouvoir
mener à bien dans sa vie mais partager
ça avec le public
voilà pourquoi on fait ça ma gueule de
l'ouest